what do you think about competition
instead of there there's been a lot of
Olympics bring this out there's been a
lot of big upsets at the Olympics
there's something where people find
something in them I mean Judo
is it is a different sport than
grappling in Judo there's much more room
for upset because a mistake in Judo
will have ramifications that will be
felt within half a second
like if you if you take the wrong grip
and Judo you can be throwing in half a
second and there's no recovery if your
two Shoulders hit the map the momentum
it's over it's done
um
in Jiu Jitsu you could especially in
ADCC where there's no points in the
first five minutes you could get taken
down and mounted by your opponent and
still win like you can recover from a
bad start in Judo boxing kickboxing
MMA you get hit there's no recovery time
you just get swarmed on and um Jiu Jitsu
is a much more forgiving sport where you
can make a series of blunders and you
just recover from them you don't make a
series of blunders and boxing you're
unconscious so that there's the blunder
case but there's also been just people
where it's their day
I mean again maybe it's romanticized in
the notion but there's been some epic
performances in Russ in Olympic
wrestling in Olympic Judo as an example
satoshiishi he had a 2008 performance we
talked about all Japan and all that kind
of stuff but the Olympics he destroyed
uh everybody on this path to the Olympic
gold medal and that's when Teddy Romero
was also competing he got the bronze so
I mean that
now you could say he was at that time
the best in the world also but he yeah
yeah but I think it would be very fair
to say he was the best in the world he
think about the people he beat to win
three old Japan championships like he
beat because in a way he beat kg Suzuki
they were Olympic Champions like he was
already so you don't believe him pretty
well
I don't believe that a person can walk
on stage and be better than
what they are supposed to be you you
have a skill level it's set in stone
this is your skill level you don't just
go on stage and suddenly your skill
level gets here what you do have is the
situation where you have a skill level
okay
another opponent has a higher skill
level but he runs into confidence issues
so that he only uses a small percentage
of his actual skills and then he will
fall below someone who is technically
lower on the skill scale than he is that
can happen
but you can't just magically acquire
skills yeah but but they're able to fall
in confidence yes so the question
becomes who manages that for best and
that can create upsets absolutely so you
don't think Gordon could have fallen in
confidence against the former teammate
when the pressure is so high there was
just no basis for a fall to occur you
said he doesn't have confidence issues
is uh what do you attribute that to
that's because he never loses in the gym
I mean there's there's nothing in the
there's no experience that he's had that
would make him say I shouldn't be this
confident so it's the physical uh it's
like uh like we talked about mental
preparation but don't get me wrong if
Gordon lost 20 matches in a row of
course his confidence would drop because
experience is now
there's going to be a psychological uh
dissonance between
uh his experience his recent experience
and what he believes okay if you believe
you're best in the world you just lost
20 matches at some point reality is
going to break in but if you're just
never losing in competition
dominating people in the gym
then there's nothing in your experience
that would shake your confidence